intermittent fasting 13 to 15 hours lose  weight you want to increase growth  hormone you want to increase  testosterone you want more ketones for  better mental clarity 13 to 15 hours  autophagy is where your brilliant body  looks within and it says okay no food's  coming so i better be a better version  of myself those cells start to repair  they kick out viruses pathogens they  kick out metals they kill cells that are  going to turn into cancer cells like you  at 17 hours of fasting you go into this  crazy repair phase at 24 hours your  whole microbiome reboots and you get  stem cells in your gut if you've been on  birth control  antibiotics mouth toxicity even removing  breast implants all of that destroys the  microbiome so throw some 24-hour fast at  it 36 hours you start to really go after  stubborn fat 48 hours and you reset  dopamine pathways in the brain and then  72 hours you reboot your whole immune  system